Nigerians in the capital take tentative
steps towards normal life after a
five-week lockdown but scenes like this
shocked medical workers on the front
lines of the fight against covet 19 it
is not a good decision at this stage and
their couple with Nigeria a system that
is not strong if we have nice number of
people who are affected we may know how
the carrying capacity of the hospital
beds to be able to take care of those
who may have been affected some of the
city's open markets remain closed
frustrating many traders have not sold
anything for more than a month
starvation everywhere people know that
and there's no provision for us the
masses so the markets be open for the
trade the lockdown has taken a toll on
miles and livelihoods and many here are
in hurry to recoup their losses the
collapse in oil prices has been another
major blow for Nigeria's all dependant
economy our stores are full we're trying
to keep the prices as they are we don't
want to even think about her losses as a
businessman your priority is to keep
your customer and good and bad times
remember many people didn't earn any
money for weeks now but some health
experts insist the government should
continue to enforce emergency measures
the government says while certain
restrictions are being lifted night care
fees will start from 8 o'clock until
further notice and wearing of masks like
this while outside and social distancing
will now be strictly enforced in
addition to reducing passenger numbers
on public transport for now places of
worship will remain closed with
government worried about enforcing
social distancing another Nigerians fear
the lifting of restrictions when
infractions are on the rise could be
disastrous
Mohammed agrees al-jazeera Abuja